[Musique]
c'est l'heure du journal de l'afrique
seuil de bien mieux sur france 24 à lyon
ce soir les pays africains qui
continuent à rapatrier leurs
ressortissants d'ukraine après le ghana
la tunisie le nigeria et l'afrique du
sud organise les rapatriements certains
pays ont décidé de mutualiser leurs
moyens pour le retour de leurs citoyens
de nombreuses ambassades de pays
africains travaillent main dans la main
les détails dans un instant et les
témoignages des étudiants africains sur
place continuent de déferler sur les
réseaux sociaux nous avons pu contacter
une étudiante congolaise elle nous
raconte son enfer sur le terrain
ukrainien alors qu'elle tentait de
quitter le pays et témoignages à suivre
enfin nous irons au kenya où les
autorités peinent à convaincre les
citoyens de se faire vacciner anaérobie
la capitale 3 millions de doses sont
stockés sans trouver preneur la plupart
des adultes refusent la vaccination
reportage de nos correspondants à suivre
dans ce journal
le retour des étudiants africains
bloqués en ukraine s'organise une
semaine après le début de l'invasion
russe des étudiants ghanéens sont
rentrés chez eux hier 106 étudiants
tunisiens étaient rapatriés grâce à un
avion militaire affrété à à bucarest le
nigeria et l'afrique du sud s'organise
également les ambassades de nombreux
pays ont décidé de travailler ensemble
pour faciliter les rapatriements shirli
enfin ils se retrouvent depuis une
semaine qui leur a paru interminable ces
familles tunisiennes étaient inquiètes
pour leurs proches principalement de
jeunes étudiants lorsque la russie a
attaqué l'ukraine ils se sont lancés
dans une course pour atteindre la
frontière
les trois derniers jours la situation
était terrible
il y avait des sirènes des banques qui
tombe et
on avait peur
nous avons marché 50 kilomètres pour y
arriver on a eu des amis qui ont été
tapés il ya eu du racisme il garde la
nourriture pour les ukrainiens
quelques dizaines de milliers de
ressortissants de pays africains
vivaient en ukraine lorsque la guerre a
éclaté des milliers ont réussi à
traverser la frontière vers la pologne
la république tchèque ou la roumanie les
premiers groupes d'étudiants ont déjà
été rapatriés au ghana plusieurs pays
comme le kenya l'afrique du sud la rdc
ont mis en place des vols pour rapatrier
leurs ressortissants
mais le chemin est encore long pour
d'autres cet étudiant nigérian s'est
retrouvé lui aussi pris dans la guerre
son père a enfin été rassuré sur son
sort nous confronter bush il est enfin
bien au chaud à cracovie
maintenant l'ambassade doit nous dire si
elle peut l'aider à rentrer au pays
face à des témoignages de traitement
raciste à l'égard de certains des
africains vivant en pologne organisent
leur accueil et une délégation de
l'union européenne au kenya un quant à
elle démenti mercredi les accusations de
racisme sans tranchée l'onu a demandé
aux pays européens de traiter tous les
réfugiés avec autant de respect
et justement va en parler du racisme
s'appelle theresia à la 25 ans et les
congolaises et l'étudier en ukraine à
odessa depuis 2010 est elle se trouve
désormais en pologne c'est lire karacena
pu la joindre à nous a raconté son
périple pour quitter l'ukraine et
surtout le racisme qu'elle a subies
écouter
21 10 projets cinq ans tout étranger
n'avait pas un traitement de faveur mais
les plus durs c'était pour les étrangers
noir comprenez c'est bientôt blanc
seront radiées pouvait passer sans essai
et pour l'humour s'il ya eu beaucoup
plus facile tant fait dirigé de l'autre
côté et avait des trucs militaires avec
des armes et touriste pointé des dames
sur nous et nous insulter et un métier
unique et hadji jeux qui vont tous
mourir rendra la tâche y avait d'autres
désert qui venait mais 12e car ces noirs
deviennent tous et d'étrangers rentrer
chez nous il nous a chipé et des gros
manquant go se demander pourquoi ils
demandent une war kids attendre il
disait qu'il n'y pensait pas être pour
le pays
des mains se battre pour les crémants
vous donner des rendez vous quatre ans
jesus lorsque l'on s'y d'espagne il y
avait des femmes avec des tpg elle était
ainsi sous le froid est devant c'est une
avait un trois jours tous les trois
étaient des gardes frontière du côté
ukrainien s'était pas des
gardes-frontières du côté polonais du
côté de la police était blesse une fois
arrivé en pologne en nous avons traversé
encore les bureaux des migrations des
militaires côté polonais était et aucun
cas ils étaient accueillants armés à
l'est
voilà pour ce témoignage que nous
n'aurions pas eu sans l'aide de notre
correspondante à kinshasa juliette du
bois alors que le conseil de sécurité de
l'onu a voté à une majorité écrasante la
résolution condamnant l' invasion russe
en ukraine beaucoup préfère rester
neutre en afrique c'est le cas de
nombreux pays comme le soudan notre
correspondant dans la région bastien
renoue il revient sur la position de
khartoum qui appelle à des négociations
mais refuse de condamner l'attaqué au
risque de froisser certains de ses
partenaires
le soudan a connu de nombreuses
pressions au cours des derniers jours de
la part des états unis de la grande
bretagne ont encore de l'union
européenne pour qu'ils acceptent de
condamner l'agression russe sur
l'ukraine alors pourquoi ces pays
veulent t'ils que le soudan condamne
cette agression a bien ce serait une
sorte de contrepartie jusqu'à la chute
d'omar el béchir en 2019 le soudan était
un pays paria exclu de nombreuses
organisations internationales sous
embargo américain et depuis la chute du
dictateur et bien il revient petit à
petit sur la scène internet lionel il
reçoit de nombreuses aides de la part
des états unis ou encore de l'union
européenne alors ces pays estiment bien
qu'ils peuvent obtenir des contreparties
en échange de cette aide c'est un
sénateur américain qui le résume le
mieux à dan kelly il explique que le
soudan doit montrer qu'il veut faire
partie de la scène internationale et que
pour ce live il doit condamner
l'agression de la russie mais c'est
extrêmement compliqué pour le pays qui a
des partenariats importants avec la
russie le groupe de mercenaires wagner
est présent au soudan la russie veut
installer une base navale sur la mer
rouge à proximité de port soudan la
deuxième ville du pays et le général
aimetti le numéro deux du régime
militaire actuellement au pouvoir et et
à moscou lorsque la guerre en ukraine a
commencé pour négocier des partenariats
avec le gouvernement russe il est donc
extrêmement difficile pour le soudan de
se priver d'un tel partenaire potentiel
le pays marche donc sur un fil depuis
quelques jours et cette guerre même si
on n'en voit pas encore les conséquences
préoccupe déjà du côté de l'egypte de
l'algérie et du nigeria ces pays
principaux importateurs de blé sur le
continent africain s'inquiètent de la
flambée des prix avec des une hausse des
cours du blé de 23 % en février le
maghreb et d'autres pays du continent
risquent d'être très impacté voilà
justement ce que l'on pouvait dire sur
l'impact de la guerre en ukraine sur sur
le continent on part à présent au togo
où des intellectuels de l'afrique de
l'ouest interpelle dans une tribune qui
vient de paraître les autorités
togolaises sur la précarité démocratique
du togo le togo est en effet le seul
pays d'afrique de l'ouest à n'avoir pas
connu d'alternance politique en plus de
50 ans parmi les signataires l'opposant
nathaniel olympio président du parti des
tobo l'écouté
le togo et du rejet par la même famille
depuis 54 ans bien sûr il ya des
élections mais les élections sont vidés
de leur substance les institutions sont
assujettis à l'exécutif et tout le monde
sait que les élections sont un jeu de
rôle finalement pour cela la démocratie
est confisquée vous savez ça bouge
partout à l'afrique de l'ouest des
révoltes par ci des coups d'état par là
la jeunesse togolaise ne supporte plus
la privation de liberté elle ne supporte
plus la privation de démocratie son
avenir est bouché elle ne supporte plus
c'est pour cela que j'appelle faure
gnassingbé à faire preuve d'ouverture
démocratique pour éviter de retomber
dans les contestations populaires et les
répressions violentes
dans la zone l'actualité en bref et en
images lui tenant colonel damiba auteurs
du coup d'état le 24 janvier dernier au
burkina faso a de nouveau été investi
mercredi président au lendemain de
l'adoption d'une charte de la transition
une charte qui prévoit une transition de
trois ans en libye le parlement a
accordé mardi sa confiance à un nouveau
gouvernement dirigé par l'ex-ministre de
l'intérieur fait les bachar à un vote
pardon à 92 voix sur les 101 députés
présents une décision qui défie le
cabinet basé à tripoli qui refuse de
céder le pouvoir avant la tenue
d'élections
la nomination de fatou bensouda la
direction de la commission d' enquête de
l'onu sur les violations présumées des
droits humains par toutes les parties au
conflit en ethiopie pour rappel la
gambienne a été procureur général de la
cpi la cour pénale internationale de
juin 2012 à juin 2021 son mandat a été
marqué par l'acquittement de l'ancien
président ivoirien laurent gbagbo et de
son ancien ministre charles blé goudé
direction le kenya le pays a en stock 3
millions de doses de vaccin contre le
coc vie 19 et seulement 27 % de la
population adulte a déjà reçu au moins
une injection le ministère de la santé a
bien tenté une campagne de vaccination
en février mais c'est un échec reportage
de bastien renouil et caroline qui meut
dans ce centre des services publics il
est désormais possible de se faire
vacciner
on vaccine contre le coc u19 ici c'est
gratuit
venez manif les mais difficile de
convaincre tout le monde le kenya a reçu
plus de doses qu'il n'en faudrait pour
répondre à la demande de la population
environ 3 millions sont stockés à
nairobi et attend d'être utilisés
une course contre la montre avant
qu'elle ne périment
anaérobie nous avons observé que pour
que les gens se fassent vacciner il faut
que le vaccin viennent eux comme ça ils
n'ont pas à se déplacer et abandonner
leurs habitudes quotidiennes don't rise
to leave you drop danon nano mode et
l'accès au vaccin est de plus en plus
facile pourtant nombreux sont ceux qui
restent méfiants dans ce quartier pauvre
de nairobi la désinformation décourage
la population certains pensent qu'ils
deviendront stérile voir quels risques
en mourir mais ce sont les effets
secondaires qui freine le plus
j'ai entendu que la piqûre peut rendre
malade et empêcher de travailler et mes
enfants comptent sur moi
je me demande beaucoup d'efforts c'est
je ne peux pas travailler pendant une
semaine que va-t-il se passer ta peau a
dit cet agent ne sont et fait du porte à
porte pour inciter les plus
récalcitrants
[Musique]
et ta famille et les vaccinés rêve ta
visite régulièrement une centaine de
maisons et de commerces depuis le début
de la pandémie selon elle 80 % de sa
communauté est désormais vaccinés au
tout début c'était très difficile de les
convaincre mais à force de venir les
voir en jour après jour et de leur
expliquer l'importance de l'injection
c'est devenu plus simple le gouvernement
espère que tous les adultes du kenya
seront vaccinés fin 2022 à l'heure
actuelle seuls 27 % d'entre eux ont reçu
au moins deux doses
voilà c'est la fin du journal de
l'afrique merci aux équipes en régime
merci aux correspondants sans qui ce
journal ne pourrait pas se faire merci à
notre chef d'édition célia karacena et
merci à vous de nous être fidèles restés
avec nous l'info continue sur france 24
[Musique]